everyone always asked me to do this one
on stream
um
[Music]
amazing
[Applause]
what's up is that Kill Bill is it that
yeah yeah where she's walking down the
corridor the Twisted nerves
[Music]
thank you
okay so obviously uh Anita we've met
before but for any new viewers or
listeners would you mind describing who
you are I'm sweet Anita and I'm kind of
an online
something I don't exactly know how else
to describe it I make content content
creator let's go with content creator
yes on YouTube and twitch primarily
mainly live stream content and I aim to
accidentally teach people stuff by
passively making them laugh I think
that's my Approach so the first thing I
wanted to ask you before we sort of get
into the story of your career is I've
never interviewed someone with
Tourette's before and I don't really
know what the etiquette is for ticks is
it polite to just ignore them or to
reference them or you know what what is
the educate me a bit on that it depends
on the person sure so like there is no
etiquette for Tourette's there's only
etiquette for the person because
everyone's condition affects them
differently like you might meet someone
and not even know they have Tourette's
because they only have one or two mild
ticks that are very quiet and then you
might see them meet someone who has like
constant explosive episodes of tits and
you know people have different
tolerances of like what they can handle
and I know some people with Tourette's
who are really really sensitive to
laughter and just don't like to be
laughed at because they're you know it
takes can be painful and you're really
challenging to navigate them and I
really don't care for me personally like
I grew up being punished for my tics
because I wasn't diagnosed as a kid so
everyone just thought I was misbehaving
so if I know that people find it funny
or that they don't care then I know that
they're not mad at me so if anything
left is reassuring compared to how
people used to react to me and so I
don't mind if people laugh I don't mind
if people want to ignore it
um I don't mind if people want to joke
about it like I have friends I have a
tick where I'll go fingers in you and
most people are just like kind of taken
aback but my friends will go yeah sure
and I've got 10 and I'll start haggling
and they know that if they agree with it
and go hmm yeah maybe a bit more like
I'll keep on ticking so and people
walking by give us looks every time and
they don't care so I have interactions
like that with my friends because they
kind of know the boundary and you you
know I kind of feel like for me I'm not
fussed how people react so long as
they're comfortable and know that I
don't mean it and I'm not really gonna
try and fist them
and did you mean it when you said Andy
had a nice ass absolutely great and was
The Tourette's present from birth or did
it suddenly ramp up and start to become
more visible at some point this really
interests me because obviously I can't
know for sure most of us don't remember
birth
um and uh sure you don't know any words
when you're you're a baby so like it's
not going to be easy to know the
difference between a twitch and just a
baby wig
um it's not like I shot out of the womb
and was just like [ __ ] off to like
everyone in the delivery room so uh how
can you really tell a lot of people say
that they suddenly had like a tick that
came on somewhere around eight nine ten
that's quite a common age for Tourette's
to start although it can start in
adulthood it can stop because medication
it can start because of
um trauma or head injuries
um and the thing with this is is my mom
said my first word was Michael's
shoesmacker wow okay and she like that
really confused my mom and dad because
they were hoping for a mum or dad they
were competing over that
um and once I said it once I would not
stop and then for many years after I
developed a vocabulary I was still
saying it out there Michael shoesmacker
Yes
um and that when I when I talked about
this I bought my mom on my stream and
asked her about this and um all of the
Formula One fans love me now
um but the thing with that was is I
don't know if I had my first word was a
tick yeah or if I had Tourette's since
birth or that I had a later onset and
that was just like my first word I don't
know for sure but it seems like my first
word was a tick and yeah
um I mean it's an impressive first word
yes exactly I thought it was like cat or
something and Michael Schumacher yeah I
wonder if I was particularly just a
quiet and observant child
um other than the ticks and perhaps I
had the capacity to speak before or
understand words before I spoke because
I was quite quiet and non-talkative for
a lot of my childhood recently looked at
my medical records and
um as far back as you go intermittently
it says neglect bad parenting quiet
um kind of flat
um emotionally flat like I'm I'm very
different to how I was in my childhood
and teens
um so I wonder if the reason why I had
such a complex first word was because I
knew like words and things I just wasn't
trying right that's interesting that's
interesting and when you when you're
saying that your childhood was never
stable so to speak
did you ever start going to school
consistently or were you kind of in and
out of school in and out so I would try
for like maybe a year of tops and then
drop for
a long period of time mostly home
educated and weirdly I was I was
teaching myself my mom would just go
here's all my University books and the
pushing about 10 year old and just being
like good luck teach me something later
and then she'd give me like books with
lines in to write and just
her like geology books and science books
and things like that and I'd go through
them I'd read them write notes down and
research them and you know my mom had
loads of loads of books at that point
because she was studying so and then at
the end of the day she'd be like what
did you find out and I'll go well and
and like even though that seems really
lazy it was great because I was learning
how to teach myself to take an interest
and take notes I was tailoring my
learning to a way that I can retain it
personally which works so much better
than school because I have ADHD right
like most people Tourette's have lots of
other diagnosis and
um so I was doing ADH free ADHD friendly
learning without realizing and
um when you re-explain something to
someone you change the way that your
brain has stored the information oh so
and so it's easier to remember and learn
things if you then pass on that
knowledge and teach someone else so
unconsciously she was teaching me in the
best possible way and I became very
advanced in these particular topics I
have like when I go to schools I have
Stacks and stacks of like awards for
like maths science English or you know
all these sorts of things I did
instantly well even though I wasn't
following the curriculum at all so you
kind of naturally academic though in
that sense yeah I mean it's kind of
lucky that I didn't go into the Sciences
because I wanted to but when I was 10 I
wanted to get men pregnant and
bioengineer mind controlling parasite
that would make people more peaceful so
I probably am glad that yes I'm also
glad you didn't
Sciences who knows what would have
happened
um okay I mean good Ambitions though uh
so so what were you like as a child at
that point like did you have a
friendship group or a couple of close
friends or any friends no I liked
animals animals don't care if you call
them a [ __ ] so
um I had I was always taking in animals
you were talking in the description
there of kind of how you dealt with in
your younger life how you dealt with the
ticks you mentioned college and
university so you'd sort of manage to
stay in education is that right you'd
sort of gone to high school then to
college and then to University I kind of
skipped High School I I think I went to
like a few months here and there across
a few middle schools and primary schools
nothing really much to speak of a year
at a high school-ish thing and then
after that
uh I think like three or four years of
isolation and then suddenly college and
that was a lot because I was agrophobic
and I was just like [ __ ] it I don't want
to live just staring at the same four
walls I'm gonna try and I was just like
having panic attacks and coming home
crying just like Ugh after like being
there for like five minutes and I just
kept going and being like I lasted 10
minutes today I lasted like an hour and
I just like kind of forced my way back
into the world and it was horrible
because like I chose
um I chose games design which was a
mistake because games design is full of
horny maladapted boys and it didn't
change like games designers like had so
many scandals those those boys grew up
that I was studying with and it just
still just as messed up and then so I
left that and went into animation which
was 40 boys and me but they were nice
boys right so uh gained all the same
skills just with fewer dicks to bat away
and um yeah that was that was great I
mean I got in by virtue of just going I
have this folder full of drawings will
you take me because uh I've heard
there's this thing called a student loan
and I'm hungry that was just kind of
like the mentality I would have gone
into science I was really passionate
about science but I didn't have any
gcses or a levels or anything to show
that I had any capacity oh wow so
instead of those you were accepted on
the course by your folder of of drawings
pictures drawings wow basically and um
they were like normally we wouldn't do
this but
um unfortunately my on my course a lot
of the people who wanted to be animators
didn't have very many drawing skills and
things and he was like in order to get
the funding for this course I need to be
able to show off like what's happening
in this course because it's relatively
new so having people drawing skills
really helped me to sell the course so
if you take your A Levels alongside the
course we'll arrange all of that for you
just make sure you pass them and then I
got my student loans and that was how I
managed to get food and stuff because I
just couldn't get employed like I would
try to get jobs but like I throw things
if I hold them for too long as a tick
and you know I'm constantly insulting
people and stuff there's just no way you
could like if I tried to stack shelves
someone's gonna get knocked out right so
yes and I suppose at that point in your
life as well you don't have a diagnosis
to be able to say I've got this by the
way in case this happens so you you were
aware that if you went and started
stacking shelves you'd end up throwing
whatever you were holding so so the
three or four years that you said that
were in isolation they were directly
after school is that right yeah I had a
bad incident at the last school and was
like [ __ ] it there's no point trying to
get an education if you're not going to
survive the education part do you want
me asking what the incident was or is it
yeah it's fine I am there were
I used to get myself in trouble a lot
with other students
um
and I would do things like there were
kids who would just try to start rumors
and things like this and they'd say I've
heard you take drugs and I'd be like yep
drugs and they'd be see she's admitting
it admitting it because like the tick
would say the most inappropriate thing
at the time or the thing that would get
me the most in trouble at the time and
unfortunately that meant that yeah I
used to get in accidental conflicts a
lot and
um I had other trouble as well I used to
beat up a lot of boys
um because I had I was an early Bloomer
which was another problem not only did I
have like a condition which makes me
shout random words at people I also had
massive tits I was like a double D at 10
I'm not even exaggerating okay so this
is a problem at school and so I had a
three warning system the first is a
don't touch me and if they kept on doing
it I'd be like I'm gonna have to hurt
you and if they kept on doing it I was
like okay what is about to happen is
your fault and like I broke one kid's
arm another kid's arm and a leg I got up
on a table and kicked another kid in the
face and these sorts of things things
like I mean these all sound reasonable
yeah they're after three warnings yeah
through warning system and uh because I
read a lot of philosophy books and had a
strong sense of Ethics okay
um but just going back to I suppose the
uh the linear nature of your life so you
were now at um you know at University
you've managed to find a course which
you like the uh game scissors no the
game design was a bad one the animation
one yeah and how was that going
well I um didn't do any animating after
I left
um
I actually uh was in an abusive
relationship towards the end of my
university studies so I was studying for
a higher degree but didn't finish that I
got my degree but at my higher degree
um ended up having to uproot my life and
move in order to escape him because he'd
already tried to kill me once and he was
he'd killed my cat and he'd wow which
this lot's just happened the last 20
seconds so you were you were sorry I
don't mean to laugh obviously yourself
but it's just kind of like
um so you so University was going okay
but you got into a abusive relationship
with obviously if there's anything that
you don't want to talk about that's too
private that's please let me know but
you got into an abusive relationship
with somebody who was a fellow student
or somebody that was older than you or
as a fellow student a fellow student and
um they tried to kill you already
yeah so I think it was in my
it goes like 20ish maybe
um and yeah he he I was with him for a
very long time but he suddenly flipped
like he was such a gentle person
um and he was kind of nerdy and quiet
and he was the kind of person who dunk
his coat in a river just to help fish a
bug out he was the kind of person he was
very like no one would think he would
her fly and I think I I got a sense of
security from that because after
everything I went through in my
childhood I was really looking for
someone gentle yeah and
um after a few years he just flipped and
he went from somebody who was very safe
to someone who's very dangerous and I
don't know it's hard because
It All Happened around the time that my
mom so we moved into a place our
landlord died and the ownership of the
house was like being debated by his
children and we were going to be have to
look for any place and we'd taken on
loads of rescue animals that we couldn't
take with us because nowhere would let
us bring pets
um so we were kind of stuck and I was
like I don't want to end up on the
streets again
um my mom's really vulnerable and these
animals are just gonna have to go to a
shelter and all the local shelters are
kill shelters
um so my ex was like because I just
recently broke up with him and he was
like
um is this is he exhibiting dangerous
behaviors at the moment after he broke
up with him or not yet not yet no like
it and then
came back and he was like I know what's
happening to you I've got an inheritance
I could buy the house I can save you and
I was like okay and he's like I need a
place to live if I can live downstairs
um then you know I can get all this
worked out I just want to help you and I
was like okay and he lived in the flat
underneath us it was a house broken up
into two and
um
he
because my mom was so grateful she was
like you know the door's always open if
you want a cup of tea if you want to
hang out all this sort of stuff and so
we'd come up into our flat and he would
you know just hang out and he just got
more and more aggressive more and more
disrespectful and he just began to
pressure me and he was horrible
um and he was like what are you going to
do about it your life's ruined like
you're homeless without me sort of thing
and oh my God the thing is I can't tell
because his family had like sudden onset
mental health problems like a lot of his
family were like fine and normal and
then one day a switch flicked and they'd
have a mental breakdown and they'd have
to be institutionalized seem to run in
the family and I don't know whether it
was that or that he's like a lot of
domestic abusers where they slowly build
into the violence after taking away your
support network after making sure that
you're financially Reliant after making
sure that you know nobody believes you
after making you look crazy to your
friends and these sorts of things
because a lot of people don't know this
about domestic violence but it's not
that people just love being abused
that's a stereotype about women oh
they're like a bad boy they always skim
over the nice guys and go for someone
who treats them like [ __ ] and it's not
true it's that all the people that do
these terrible things lie so that every
person looks like a decent person until
they get the opportunity to hurt you and
get away with it and so a lot of them
build into it they start picking fights
with your family so you've got no
support network they start you know make
ice you know isolating you from your
friends they start controlling your food
and making you hungry and tired arguing
with you long into the night until
you've just lost all sense of time and
space and so you're confused and tired
and weak and it's then that they'll hit
you and then they'll say that you
imagined it or that you deserved it or
just lighting gaslighting and so they
build into the violence and people don't
see that they just see their friend who
you know
just get this douche bag and you can see
it from the outside really easily and
you just don't see how they make it
invisible from the inside at all
okay and then so and he killed your cat
as well he did
um but how I still don't know I just
know that um he used to come in for a
specific window we'd always leave it
open for the cat then one day he stopped
coming home and at this exact same day
and he started closing the window and
I'd open it again so he already knew the
cat wasn't coming back and then one day
I went down
um after he like I moved out in a hurry
I used a domestic violence
um organization to get away right
um and in that situation I had to
quickly go down and remove a couple of
pieces of furniture he'd take in from me
um and he I pulled the furniture back
and there was just fur and blood all up
the wall
um and it was all his Ginger fur and I
was like ah okay oh my God
so and the thing is like the police are
just use this I I tried at the police
there's just uh
so
wow okay and how old are you at this
point I was in my early 20s early 20s
okay but yeah I moved on from that got a
new partner who wasn't that great he
wasn't abusive but he was not great he
stole eight grand for me cheated on me
definitely not great I would say is um
accurate yeah and uh so that that was
not great either but I ended up starting
a business and selling things online and
became completely self-efficient because
um like self-sufficient because I I [ __ ]
cats I basically was no one was stupid
enough to employ me so I just had to
employ myself and what were you selling
so I started off with sea glass
um which is kind of these Pebbles made
of glass you know when you throw trash
out
um if any glass ends up in the sea it'll
get eroded like oh yes I know what you
mean like soft it's kind of opaque yeah
yeah and it ends up frosted on the side
yes and some of them are like hundreds
of years old and like some of them make
you know people make jewelry out of them
but they can also be worth quite a lot
of money and uh I
yeah I sold that first because it was
free and I didn't know I could sell it I
just liked finding it it was very
therapeutic I was going through a
processing stage where I was going down
to the beach just to get away from
looking after my mom and just to have
some time with my own thoughts because
obviously A lot's happened in my life
and I just needed some processing time
so I'd just pick it up just because it
was fun and then I found out that other
people online were picking it up and
that they were trading it selling it so
I set up a little online shop but I sold
sea glass and then I saved up the money
and bought craft supplies that I knew
were hard to get for my animation degree
and then I sold those and I turned over
the money and turned it over again and
eventually I rented a couple of offices
and I filled them with dick I filled
them with cat I filled them with like
stock and then [ __ ] off I started
selling it from there which was fun
because it was a stock the sea glass or
the animation supplies so the craft
supplies at this point both both at one
point and slowly just shifted just to
craft supplies right
um and then I was in this big office
building with two offices adjacent to
each other one for stock one for posting
and stuff and people would walk by to
their offices and they'd never meet me
but they'd hear me
um so I always wonder what they were
theorizing my job was right packaging
things off all the time yeah but just
hearing me like shout I [ __ ] cats and
stuff
you know I do wonder what they thought
it was doing
um and the postman would always warn
each other about me which was really
amazing so uh basically I received a lot
of parcels because I had I had a lot of
stuff to sell and I'd order it in so
they'd drop off the parcels and I have a
problem with like smacking things out of
people's hands right and I also have a
spanking tick so like like there was at
least a couple of post posties who I'd
smack it other hands they'd turn around
to pick it up I'd spank them and then
and I'd be like I am so sorry
um and they'd be like it's okay it's
okay and they just tell each other like
you should be careful I wonder what they
were saying though I don't know but like
one time I one knocked on the door and I
was like nice [ __ ] and he was like oh I
was told about you
um reputation preceded you there yeah
um so that was fun I I quite enjoyed my
uh posty conversations and things
um and then I started playing OverWatch
um my ex-boyfriend the bad one
um but not so bad this new boyfriend he
um he got me into OverWatch and I kept
the OverWatch and dumped the boyfriend I
was like this is fun but you're not and
uh I was on OverWatch that I found
twitch because a streamer found me so um
I was doing twitch as a like a mild
Hobby and it wasn't even I didn't even
know people could make a living off it I
was literally just streaming my game so
people could see when there was an
opening and join me and then that was
all it was for it wasn't it was just a
social thing for me
um and so at this point you're
essentially you've become just a
self-sufficient person that's doing your
um sales work and basically doesn't need
to talk anyone except Postman who you
spank right that's basically your your
interactions um but just for people who
are listening or watching that might not
be fully aware can you just explain
firstly what OverWatch is and secondly
what twitch is I know that seems like an
obvious thing but you know we have a
very big audience varied ages Yeah Yeah
so basically
uh OverWatch is an online game you can
it's like a first person shooter
um you are in a team of five or six and
then you fight each other and you can
have you can communicate with your team
um so I had a headset on I'd have a mic
and I'd hold down the button to talk and
then lift it and you couldn't hear me
again ah okay and that meant people met
me before my condition which was great
because the people that did like me who
knew that I had my condition were
annoying they were like
um so at this point in my life I was I
pretty sure I had Tourette's I had a
very strong suspicion I'd actually
started going to the hospital and asking
for tests and things
um so I said it was suspected Tourette's
and so I'd preface it with that I was
like I have what might be Tourette's I'm
sorry if I say anything weird I don't
mean it and so then I'd be like oh my
God I love Tourette's and stuff like
things like big brother and stuff like
oh can I show you to my friends they
would love that and oh would you spank
my friend and I was just like oh and I
hated it so I ended up
um like the way I coped with it was I'd
make online friends on this game and
they wouldn't know I had Tourette's
because we pushed to talk I could just
lift up my finger and I'm muted that's
so interesting because one of the things
that I was going to say was I thought
OverWatch was an interesting choice of
game for you because of the fact that
you've got the team play so you'd be
talking over the choice of a game where
you didn't have to communicate in that
way yeah but it makes complete sense
because you had you could control when
they could hear you speaking or making
sounds or anything like that and it made
it really appealing because people were
meeting me before my condition and they
were liking me for who I am because when
I first started saying it might be
Tourette's I got a lot of acceptance
um they're like oh I understand what's
going on now but then they were like
over romanticizing it weird so this gave
me an Avenue to navigate my condition
and have friends and I was very
talkative and it taught me so many
important social skills like if anyone's
listening who's really lonely and
doesn't know how to connect with people
online gaming is such a great way
because you have so many throwaway
interactions so if you [ __ ] it up there
are no consequences and a lot of people
use that to be abusive but it's really
great for practice of learning how to
make conversation make small that's
interesting ease people in and so I feel
like that's when I started being like
less socially inept was there and I
suppose what you got from the push to
talk thing is what most other people
have which is a control over what they
say right so did that feel like a
completely new way of interacting with
people or was it kind of like this is
what I've always wanted to be able to do
yeah absolutely it was great I mean a
lot of my friends there I so I made a
bunch of friends that became my mods
when I started twitch
um and they didn't know I had Tourette's
back then
um they thought I was a voice actor for
one of the characters because I ended up
having a tick and I could replicate a
voice which one it was Tracer oh okay so
Teresa's like meant to be this British
girl yeah she has like one of those
forced Mary Poppins on crack kind of
accents that like the Americans think we
have yeah even though we don't and so it
annoyed me and that made it a tick and
so I just kept repeatedly saying it
until like it was so spot-on that people
thought that I was a voice actor and
sometimes I troll them right and like
sometimes they thought I was a
soundboard like I played a drinking game
quite often on Friday nights where I'd
whack out like some vodka or something
poor shots and it'd be like every time I
get accused of being a soundboard
um I have to take a shot and so I play
the game and I'd be like I would just
use whatever voices I could because I
have so many that I can do and I would
just like push down the button say
something and they'd be like oh nice
sound dude bro I bet you're a fat dude
from America stop it turn off the sound
board bro and I'll just be like oh no
he's really like and then say it too
often I'll be like oh but it's
interesting you say that about the um
what you say that about them thinking
you've sounded like Tracer because
uh I remember the first time I saw you
online I can't remember which video it
was it might have even been the sidemen
Tinder one potentially but I remember
like I couldn't quite place where I
thought you were from like I thought you
had a slightly American accent yeah um
weirdly it's a fun fact about Tourette
Syndrome
um a lot of us have like really bad
infectious accent like we we pick up
um sounds really easily and accents
really easily and I know this not
because it's well documented but because
I'm in a lot of communities for people
with Tourette syndrome and like
community discords and things and I was
like I pick up accents really fast and I
often tick in other accents as well like
I'll tick and I'll sound really American
or really Irish or something out of the
blue
um and they're like oh yeah I have that
too and then there was a stream of like
50 people going that is exactly me and I
was like is this a Tourette's thing
because we're all saying this
um so a lot of us mimic sounds anyway as
a tick like it's quite often there's
something called echolalia which is the
form of tick where you say back to
someone what they just said to you and
it gets you in a lot of trouble because
people think you're just being childish
right you know if you like like could
you move the chair like can you move the
chin like so people get really annoyed
with it it's quite a tough tick to have
socially but it means that from a very
young age you're replicating everything
you hear
um I have uh yeah this sounds so much
like the alert and I have a
so sometimes they sound more American
because I'm surrounded by Americans I'm
on Twitch most of twitch is operated by
Americans most of the big streamers are
American most of the people I'm
socializing with because of that is
American people so it seeps in and then
I'll spend like two days in London and
sound British again right it's it's
really frustrating and it's funny you
say that about the the whistle thing
because we did a video before where we
discussed with you about the fact that I
think am I right in thinking that you've
used whistling to to cover ticks at one
point oh yeah I mean I live near a
school so if I walk home at the wrong
time I'll be offering to fist children
great okay so when you know that certain
tics are very very threatening you learn
strategies emergency strategies but a
lot of people Tourette Syndrome don't
tick when they're making music like
that's one of the things that quite
universally helps a lot of people
Tourette Syndrome so because
um you're forced to do this thing in
order to not take you off often end up
getting very good at something I know a
streamer with Tourette's who's a drummer
and he's a fantastic drummer because
when he drums he doesn't ticks it's a
break from his condition
um and for me whistling is a way to like
I can't just carry a flute or like a
banjo with me everywhere I go it's just
like cope with difficult situations so
whistling is just something I can
passively do
um after your mum after that after after
um when I'm in a when I'm in a situation
where
um I can't escape and I don't want to
um come across as weird like in an
escalator or like there are situations
where I know like once I went into a
bathroom and there were a bunch of black
girls stood at the mirror and I kept
ticking the N word over and over again
oh my God am I gonna come out and have
an altercation because I don't know if
I'm gonna have enough time to explain
and you know these sorts of situations
are really tough so whistling is a good
way to be the weirdo whistling instead
of the the Widow offering to fist your
grandma yes that's understandable and
and the byproduct you told us before is
that you're amazing at Whistling yeah
well I I'd like to think I've Gotten
Good at it we did this before in a video
and it got so many comments where we
asked you to give us just a blast of
something you're really good at we're
saying can I ask you to do it again sure
let me think of a song Oh everyone
always asked me to do this one on stream
um
[Music]
amazing
[Applause]
what's up is that Kill Bill is it that
yeah yeah where she's walking down the
corridor the Twisted Nerve song yeah
yeah it's incredible so
um you'd started playing OverWatch with
your ex-boyfriend had you been into
gaming before that or was that the first
time you sort of experienced it it was
my first time online gaming I loved the
last of us and um console games and
whenever I was younger I loved console
games because it was a way to pass time
without having to socialize you know you
can swear it can be at games yeah I just
think you're angry like at the game so
it was it was an easy way to enjoy
myself without too much threat and I
could focus as well so a lot of the time
I wouldn't even tick so it I loved games
growing up I used to play the Super
Nintendo and the the PS1 and then my
mom's she we were really strapped for
money when I was growing up but she once
she like did that thing where you can
pay in increments over
she got me like a PS2 and that was a
great sense of escapism for me
especially when I was very isolated so
yeah I loved gaming but I'd never really
played with other people
so are we good at it
I'd like to think so but I guess that's
subjective sure but I mean as somebody
that hadn't spent a lot of time
socializing with people I I got
OverWatch and a group of me and this
years ago when it came out a group of me
and me and a group of workmates all
played it and I was rubbish at it and so
online just got a ton of abuse
so I guess you sort of if you're someone
that isn't used to talking in groups and
you go into playing on the online
community you must have to be quite good
otherwise people are just gonna
slam you for being too rubbish to play
with them honestly I don't remember
because I got accused of being a
soundboard too often sure okay so I was
pretty drunk a lot of my own because you
were playing that drinking game yeah so
I have no idea whether we're good
um but I know that I got into
Competitive Gaming since so I do like
first person she is I've been in a lot
of Apex tournaments and one
prize money from those and like actually
done all right so I'd like to think that
I'm okay at it yeah well you're being
very humble if you're winning prize
money I mean you must be really good at
it so then uh you moved on to Twitch and
again would you mind just explaining for
anyone who's unfamiliar what is Twitch
so twitch is an online live streaming
platform it's kind of like watching
television but it's all happening in the
moment so people have channels and
they're dedicated to their own content
so anyone can start a twitch Channel you
can just hop on make your account and
turn on your camera and stream to the
masses and it's not likely that you'll
get more than one viewer at first and
some people grind at it and they stream
for hours every day to like one or two
viewers for years and years hoping to
make it big but I didn't know that
people could make it big I didn't do any
research I didn't look up any streamers
I literally found out about it because I
was playing OverWatch a guy came over
into my game and I just got chatting
with him he didn't like tomatoes and uh
I was like how could you not like
tomatoes and we were just talking and
his viewers thought I was either a
soundboard a voice actor or a streamer
they're like she's got to be one of
these three things so they were Googling
me and they couldn't find me because I
wasn't any of those things
um and basically
he said I've got a confession I'm
streaming I was like that's all right I
don't even know what that is
um and
he gave me a link I saw his chat and I
was like well if I'm passively doing
what it takes to be one of these three
things why don't I give it go so I made
an account and yeah I just used it to
hang out with my friends because I got
chatty and most of the gamers
in OverWatch were dudes so if they hear
a woman's voice and then they figure out
it's not soundboard at some point they
will drop your friend request so I ended
up with more than 200 friends um and
when I whenever I went online that was
like 50 60 70 messages hey hey hey hey
and I only have like six Lots so I was
like I'm not gonna spend two hours
getting back to everyone I'm just gonna
stream it and I'll be like eh I'm
streaming now and then people could see
if I had like a full team or whatever
and that worked really great for me
um so immediately as soon as I started I
had like 20 average viewers which is 20
at any given time and over 100 like
viewers that in total that had come to
the stream so I was like this is doing
really well usually people have to work
really hard for this
um so I kept on doing that then people
paid a lot of attention to my condition
because all of these friends had no idea
I had Tourette's they're not hearing the
ticks and suddenly on the live stream I
have no there's no push to talk on the
live stream yeah so so they're hearing
all the extras and they're like what is
happening and I start having to explain
Tourette syndrome and at this point
actually
it was just after I finally got my
diagnosis ah okay at what age was this
sorry about 27. so okay so quite late
yeah because
um what happened was I got some tests in
my early 20s then had to leave town and
um because of everything that happened
with my ex and then
um they were supposed to message me and
tell me the results but they never did
and I never chased it up because my life
was just thrown into turmoil so
um
I got in contact with them and was like
hey I we were investigating whether I
had Tourette Syndrome could we look into
that again because I never got any
answers and I I really I can't get a job
it's really getting in the way of my
life I need help and they were like
oh we diagnosed you like nearly 10 years
ago I was like what I was like yeah I
looked through your records you have
Tourette Syndrome we've known for quite
a while oh my God if you'd have told me
back then hopeful this would yeah this
would have been life-changing so you
were diagnosed at 17 but you only found
out at 27 as well I said like nearly 10
years ago it's like sometime in my early
20s like it was either 20 21 23
somewhere around there
um and so I finally had it and I I got
my medical records printed out and I was
like there it is and it was so
liberating because I was like no I'm out
of therapy could have stopped me from
all those slaps and Willy warps because
I used to whop people and just all sorts
of terrible things and I was like I felt
so guilty I was like why am I such a
terrible person but when I found out
that it was Tourette's and for sure I
was like this isn't something that I
could help it wasn't something I could
choose not to do
um and I just felt this release and I
got to be able to defuse situations
because people were like oh my God what
are you doing I'm like I have Tourette's
really sorry and immediately people are
nice like I was in the quiet train
because there were no other seats
um and one and this lady came over to me
and went excuse me is that your phone
and um I was like no I I have it's a
tick I'm doing it and I I can't stop is
it bothering you I'm really sorry and
she went I am so I'm so sorry and she
went from like Karen mode to like and
the whole train went silent was just
watching and smirking
um and do people know what Tourette says
do you think in general the most is it
is it in public self-consciousness now
is a condition nowadays I'd like to
think so yeah
um I'd say Millions upon Millions more
people now know than ever
um and
I think that wasn't the case when I was
young at all I mean even I had vaguely
heard of Tourette Syndrome as a child
and decided I didn't have it because
like yes I have these random things I
say but like my idea of Tourette
Syndrome didn't fit what I was
experiencing everyone has a stereotype
of Tourette Syndrome they all think it's
swear word sudden and non-complex just
you shout [ __ ] every now and again but
like I would sit there and I'd have
these long complex ticks or I'd have
motions that I'd do over and over again
and things like that and I was like nah
it's like Tourette's but it's not
um and so I think it's much more well
known and much more well understood by
the public now uh which is fantastic
because it's infinitely safer to leave
my house I've been kicked off buses and
in places I've traveled to places even
now where people don't understand
Tourette's very much like America and
like lost thousands in plane tickets
because of the chaos it's caused
um oh wow even somewhere like America or
an airline or something like that they
don't they don't have an awareness of
what it might be wow well so you've been
kicked off the planes or you just
haven't been allowed to board or well
they don't kick you off mid-flight but
they do um yeah they will deny you entry
if you're being abusive or causing a
scene um I do ask for special assistance
and there is a whole process for that
that but the special assistance is
reserved for people with disabilities
that are very visible so they'll we'll
walk up to and go ah you're this person
here for special assistance right and
I'll go yep and they'll go I've got this
wheelchair for you let's go and I'm like
I don't need a wheelchair and they're
like well I don't know anything about
that good luck and I'm like oh [ __ ]
because now I've got to go through all
these cues without spanking anyone or
eating someone's baby like I I just I
don't know what to do say like in these
situations it can be really really
challenging
um and it's it causes chaos every I've
got a terrible travel story for every
time I take a house have you ever eaten
a baby not yet plenty of time
okay all right well so now
um we've got the um we've got the sort
of twitch started up and you're you're
doing that and that's going quite well
and it's growing
at what point did that become a thing
that you thought oh this is actually a
thing this isn't a hobby
when I would have to pay to go to work
so I was making not that much money but
it was enough for me to be very
comfortable and happy because like I'd
grown up really poor so like I was
making like 1800 a month which was more
than I needed and
I was like if I go to work today
I'll make three four times less than if
I just stay home order in some junk food
and play computer games for three hours
wow yeah and I was like when their right
mind would go to work today so I closed
my shop
for a week thinking I've gone viral
because of my Tourette's people will get
bored of me shouting [ __ ] eventually and
then I'll have to go back to work but
for now free holiday paid holiday let's
go
um and then nobody left and I'm still
here four years later
[Music]
um so and now people pay me even more to
play computer games because it's not
just that people could because on Twitch
people can donate so people can
subscribe for like five pounds a month
um to support you and keep you streaming
there are tears to Subs so you can have
tier two tier three which is more money
they're giving you then there's bits
which is basically
currency like in twitch that equates to
money they pay you a real money but
based on how many bits people give you
and then there's actual PayPal donations
direct PayPal donations and there's
infrastructure set up so that you know
people are chatting live you know you
can see chats scrolling by but people
also pay for their message to be read
out to you and the audience and things
like this so you're engaging with people
and you know you're getting paid and you
can see at the end of the month how much
a month you're going to get paid because
of all of these subscriptions and then
on top of that you can get sponsorships
if you are successful enough the
companies who run these games start to
notice you and go will you play my game
too
um because we really like it to be
popular and um so you end up being
offered like someone's just like have a
few grand play my game for a few hours
and you're like I would have paid to
play this game sure
is it that simple let's just play it for
a few hours you don't need to say you
like it or do you know you do have to
say you like it is it just as simple as
play this game and we'll give you some
money it depends
depends say you don't like it I'm like I
have Tourette's you're basically that
sentence is just guaranteed that I will
say I don't like it I once had a
contract like that I think and it really
put the anxiety up me sure and I don't
know which sponsorship it was but
immediately as soon as I started playing
the game I just went this game is [ __ ]
that's okay and like all of the chat was
like yep yep just agreeing I was like
well goodbye they still paid me they
still paid me I was surprised the check
came in I was like really do it again
okay
um and so what at what point was it from
when you first turned on your first ever
uh twitch stream to closing that shop
the process you just described how long
was that uh so because I have anxiety
and I'm not very secure in my
connections because of my childhood and
stuff I think I was probably fine to
completely close up my office
um within like two or three months wow I
didn't I kept it there waiting for me to
go back to work for like a good year oh
wow renting the office just as a plan B
yeah because I was like any minute now
they'll be bored of me any any minute
any minute now and they just never left
so I just had that anxiety for so long
that I kept it on standby for that long
and there were so many repeat buyers
because I was selling stuff you couldn't
really find much anywhere and so there
were lots of buyers who were like hello
are you gonna come back
um but yeah I I have that still as Plan
B Because it's what I did for a living
was really fun basically I would go out
to the beach every morning at Sunrise
pick up sea glass hang out with all the
wildlife give the crows some peanuts and
stuff make all my animal friends happy
come back wash it all so I will watch
Netflix while I get them all packaged up
and everything so Beach Walk Netflix
message a few people take some stuff to
the post office and then just saw any
like crafts applies into little bags
ready to be posted instantly and stuff
that does sound really nice yeah just I
would rock up in my pajamas every day
swear at my PC not bother anyone it was
great so yeah you know I'm I'm fine like
the thing is like I've been doing Twitch
in a very relaxed way kind of I mean it
eats all my time it's what I do 24 7
because I it's I'm really passionate
about it but like I'm not doing it for
like a huge career otherwise it'll
probably be slightly less opinionated
um so I
I get to not take it too seriously which
has kept me going because when you've
seen someone say get your tits out for
the 6 000th time you can get a bit
wearing but if you're not taking it too
seriously and you know there are really
no consequences if you [ __ ] up your
career tomorrow it makes being a content
creator much easier
um and I like talking because talking
helps with the ticks because I have
really bad dyslexia and communication
issues
um parts of my brain are really
underactive and
um it's a struggle to speak so it takes
a lot of focus well then that that's an
interesting point because you talked
earlier about when you did the gaming
degree about the guys you're with you
weren't very keen on and then what you
just said there about the comments you
get on twitch sometimes
what's the Dark Side of becoming famous
on the internet
um
how long have you got
because uh it's not what people think it
is at all in a good way or a bad way
both okay both yeah the Dark Side of
Fame I could tell you so many stories I
mean between stalkers the sexual
harassment the weird security messages
that you have to take
um how it alienates you from your
friends and how people treat you
differently in a way that makes it
really difficult and Hollow to connect
with people
um so on an emotional level it changes
everything on a social level it changes
everything Financial
um it changes everything uh I think
being a woman has a lot to do with it as
well oh yeah but it's as with many jobs
there's like dude mode and hard mode so
like I get I get hard mode as a woman on
Twitch
um there will be things that no man will
ever face on Twitch
um but women will get all the time and
there's a stereotype that all you have
to be is pretty on Twitch and people
shower you with money and you'll always
get instant success but I've seen that
less than one percent of the
less than one percent of streamers make
more than a thousand pounds per year
from Twitch streaming oh wow
statistically virtually impossible to
succeed as a streamer I had no idea that
was a start that's crazy and then uh the
top 300 there's like two or three women
so like the most the top 300 most
successful streamers are mostly men and
there's just a different criteria for
men than there is women so a
disqualifying criteria for me is I'm not
allowed to have sex
because if I have a boyfriend or a
partner
um people will unsubscribe and stop
watching and it's people think it's
because when viewers watch a woman it's
just because they fancier that women
don't have any real content and that the
only thing they have a value to The
Gaming Community is just boobs but the
thing with that is is that's not
actually what's happening
I genuinely think that what's happening
is that because the Gaming Community is
mostly male this isn't because men are
better at computer games it's because
when compute games were first marketed
they were only marketed as a boy's toy
so people were buying them for Christmas
when they first came out for their boys
so young girls didn't really have much
incentive and much of an introduction to
gaming 30 years ago and so it became a
boys club just by virtue of marketing
people just assumed girls wouldn't like
them which was wrong but it meant that
there's this huge community of boys who
were socially inept doing High you know
hiding from reality in games and so they
didn't learn a lot of social skills
because they would isolate it like me I
had low social skills games were a
refuge for me too it's not criticism but
what it means is that when it becomes a
social club and people are starting to
play together you're mostly going to
find men with low social skills who kind
of resent women for not [ __ ] them and
then you know you enter that space and
they're all aggressive towards you
constantly install and rejecting you
they don't cooperate with you if you do
call outs in the game like there's a
shooter over there or whatever they're
not going to listen to you so it's
harder to learn how to cooperate it's
harder to learn those team skills
because there's a 50 to 90 chance no
one's really gonna listen to you or help
you as a woman so when you jump into
that environment to test the waters
that's a lot different to trying Mario
30 years ago to test the waters most
girls are turned off these games now so
there's a barrier to entry and only
women with a certain character type will
get in and even then it'll take
perseverance and you know that that
means there's this bottleneck where it's
mostly dudes and they're mostly straight
socially inept dudes when you're Twitch
streaming to a Gaming Community which
twitch is largely gaming
um what happens is um
these guys will listen to you for
whatever content you're making but not
many men growing up are taught how to
differentiate between admiring a woman
and wanting to possess her we don't
really let men take on feminine
interests so like men as young boys
can't dress up as their favorite female
characters because they'd be ridiculed
they'd be accused of being gay they'd be
you know insulted it was considered the
meaning for man to behave feminine so
boys aren't taught how to look up to
women how to look across at women how to
hang out with women the narratives
they're told are you just earn them for
doing cool [ __ ] like save the world and
the girl
um there aren't very many narratives
where boys and girls are friends where
it isn't just like a slow romance where
she may make noises where she has a
choice and stuff but really he'll earn
her in the end because he's done all the
good [ __ ] like that's the narrative boys
grows up boys grow up with so a lot of
these socially inept boys who weren't
raised among girls
learn that if they like something a girl
it must mean they fancy them it's a
really common mistake and I know I'm
generalizing here and that a lot of you
know most men in normal society are
capable of relating to women but in this
insular gaming Society full of redditors
and 4chan and just all this stuff like
this is a very common mentality
um and you face it a lot on Twitch and
this means that if you are gaming and
producing perfectly good content people
will become infatuated with you because
they just they go I admire you that must
mean I fancy you I can't imagine
relating to a girl for any other reason
um and so if you have a partner you're
views will drop because not because they
ever thought they had a chance with you
not because they thought their
subscription was going to buy them a
[ __ ] it's literally because
they're jealous it makes them
uncomfortable they're suddenly comparing
themselves to somebody else and so your
content went from being fun to making
them uncomfortable because they're like
well I'm cool too and you'd have
probably rejected me because you're a
[ __ ] and he probably has a bigger dick
than me and I don't like this anymore I
feel feelings that run comfy and so
people are just uncomfortable around
women who aren't sexually available even
if they never plan to have sex with them
just because of every a relatability
barrier that has been cultivated have
you ever seen that Reddit sub uh nice
guys yes that was my first sort of
exposure to how prevalent that is where
for anyone listening or watching that
doesn't know this sub is basically just
people posting well mostly women
unfortunately posting interactions with
uh guys on the internet where the sort
of template for an interaction is hey
how are you hey I'm fine how are you
good do you want to get a drink sometime
oh sorry I've got a boyfriend [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah yeah not even put like the
amount of those kind of posts and they
say I
that feels quite the first time I saw
that I was kind of like oh my God
because it's just thousands of posts a
day of people saying the same thing that
that's how the interactions go and to
hear you explain it like that
actually is is really good it's a very
um it's a very clear way of explaining
where that process has all come from and
the kind of lack of social skills and as
you describe uncomfy feelings and is
that something you deal with like do you
think with twitch there's also an odd
thing about the fact that people are
giving money do you think that they feel
that gives them some kind of ownership
or that you owe them something for the
money I'm learning not at all unless I'm
just full of very submissive viewers
because right okay roast them and sass
back and I will not act really grateful
for money that comes with an insult
um and people really enjoy that like you
if you're honest to a fault people crave
that on Twitch because do you get like
big donations do you know do you ever
get those kind of things where it's like
a big donation with an immediate sort of
follow-up about
you or do you want to meet or do you
want to hang out or
I think I'm way too well known okay
I have people give me a huge sums of
money with no expectations here's the
brand buy yourself a new pc you're
lagging like this sort of stuff
um that's happened since the beginning
um some some viewers have felt entitled
to meetups and things like this and I
learned very early on I made a perilous
mistake when I was like a 20 viewer Andy
um where this guy was like hey I'm in
like Devon do you want to meet and I was
like not in my town I don't want anyone
to know where my town is and he was like
okay maybe in an adjacent town or
something I was like fine I you know you
give me so much of your time watching my
show like why not and so I met up with
him and he was really weird
um I said I can only meet up with you
for now I've got to care for my mom and
he was like yeah that's fine as soon as
it's set off he was like I hope you're
gonna make it worth my while I hope
you're not going to waste my time I have
traveled a long way I hope you're not
just gonna shoot straight after an hour
I was like that's what we agreed on
already getting weird and then I paid
for the feet we sat ate a meal had a
conversation and uh I paid for the food
he's like I've never had a date by the
food I was like this was never a date
what you want about and he was like uh
you'll see I was like no I really won't
and then he I went to the train station
a little early because I was already fed
up with this and um he was like before
you go can you come back to my car I
want to give you a gift and I followed
him to the car park at a distance he got
to the car and he was like come closer
it's all right and I was like uh so I
stayed like out of Arm's Reach and he'd
lost his keys and he was like wait right
there I just need to get my keys I had
such a terrible feeling about this so I
went to the train station while he was
gone he came back and was like you've
got to come back I'm having a
hypoglycemic attack I'm diabetic I'm
dying and I was like why are you texting
me instead of calling an ambulance and I
was on the train and I was I was like
I'm sorry good luck I'm already on the
train and um he was absolutely fine and
we ended up Banning him from my Discord
Community because he was saying
obsession is natural rape is natural
it's the natural order of things you
can't tell me a single Society where
women dominated you just can't it's
men's natural place all this sort of
stuff so I left the VC and was like he's
a bit of a creep and he said come back
here you stupid little [ __ ] in like DMS
just like get back in the VC now you
coward and all this stuff it's like no
burning this guy I'm really glad he
didn't find his keys
um and from there I learned that
nobody's entitled to my time just
because they watch and I'm glad I
learned that really early yeah but I
mean it's quite a terrifying story isn't
it because
just have you've described it there's a
lot of ways where that could have gone
much much worse and the thought that
people with just 20 uh viewers or
whatever 20 subscribers could be
attracting this kind of personality who
will then travel to meet them in person
and have slightly odd motivations is
worrying oh it gets worse I had a guy
camping my back Garden he assaulted me
and then
um the police caught him on his way to
my house with a knife he'd constantly
threatened to kill me while I was live
on stream he's like I know where you
live and I'm coming over to kill you and
all this sort of stuff and he wasn't
dealt with for a long time and so yeah
things can get very very serious very
fast and do you think that's something
do you think you've been for one of a
better word unlucky or do you think
that's when you talked with a female
streamers is it experiences that they've
had as well this is the industry
standard for females on Twitch oh God so
basically what I'd say is if you're a
woman who's new to Twitch I'd say only
join if you don't have any social media
if you have any social media with your
full name
maybe don't bother if you are planning
to stream delete all that before you
start second
um never tell anyone your real name
never talk about your hometown disguise
your room it has to be a blank wall any
defining feature a window a beam a
banister anything people will look
through thousands upon thousands of
housing listings to find that one house
with that detail from when it was listed
in like whenever whatever year it
doesn't matter how far back it was and
they will find your exact address and
post it all over the Internet and
encourage each other to attack you stalk
you and this sort of thing and no
distance will be too far I had someone
fly from the Netherlands I've had
someone fly from America I've had a few
people fly from America to harass me so
don't just think oh I live in a remote
place this won't happen to me fly over
because I think if they come over you
and then we'll be able to be in a
relationship or just because they want
to upset you or harass you or hurt you
mixture of both I mean most stalkers
mentality I could write books and books
on stalkers and psychology of it you get
different kinds but the a very common
one for women is specifically the I'm in
love with you we're meant for each other
you just don't know it yet you're my
soul mate and if I could just get you to
talk to me for five minutes you'll
understand what do I have to do to get
you to talk to me for five minutes oh if
I insult you you'll buy me that means
you read my message I'll make a new
account what can I say this time she
reacted again one day she'll react
enough and she'll she'll see and so um
they'll make a count after account after
account doesn't matter how many times
you block them they'll start like trying
to look up your friends and family
social media they'll pretend to have no
idea who you are and they'll make
friends with them and they'll you know
just make casual conversation and try to
learn little tidbits about you passively
um maybe they'll start hanging out with
your siblings or a relative and start
going to their home in the hopes that
one day you'll come over at the same
time
um they'll do things like this
constantly anything anything to get five
minutes with you because then you'll see
and so it doesn't matter how extreme the
behavior becomes if it gets a reaction
out of you they're making progress and
so they could be threatening to kill you
but they think at one point it will mean
that you'll love them and so it's not
like traveling over to get you to marry
them it's traveling over because I've
just got to talk the tragedy of this
conversation is you know where we
started was somebody that had no way of
interacting with society and wanted to
know how and then found a way that they
could interact with Society comfortably
and then it turns out Society is
horrible
well
um I think for me I had seen a lot more
of the dark side of humanity and only
the Dark Side of humanity growing up I
mean I saw my mom have a terrible
chronic illness that wasn't diagnosed
for 20 years just because they just
didn't believe her that's a really
common thing
um and then when she was finally
diagnosed it was too late to operate on
so her life is ruined
um and so I saw the dark side of the
medical community and how that's
incredibly sexist but then I also saw
um like the lady with the meat cleaver
abusing animals
um who turned me vegan for life
um and then I saw these terrible men who
simultaneously said I love you but we're
trying to kill you or beat you
um I also had the boys who wouldn't
respect my boundaries until I beat some
scents into them and the boys that beat
me unconscious and I saw a lot of
violence I saw a lot of horrible
behavior and not a lot good so I feel
like I got more of a glimpse of the good
side of humanity now than ever because a
lot of twitch's people who want to give
someone their time want to listen to
what other people have to say want to
give want to support and that's the
majority of twitch twitch wouldn't
operate if it wasn't by majority of
those people and so it's very easy to
pay attention to the dark side because
we're primates and if we ignore good
things they run silently in background
if we ignore bad things they could kill
us and so evolutionarily speaking it's
so easy to see a thousand comments
saying you're beautiful I love you sweet
Anita you're so funny and then see one
comment that says you have a big nose
and you'll remember that for the rest of
the day
so
um I feel like now because I'm very well
practiced in looking at the good and
appreciating it I
I feel fine with knowing about the bad
and I'm actually really glad that the
bad people come to my stream
specifically because I run I run
alongside a charity that provides mental
health care and helps support
financially people who can't afford it
and things like this so I have a link my
community you can make link use of and
it's a really passive roast when someone
comes and acts up and is like sexually
harassing you and stuff and you're like
if you're feeling lonely and a bit
desperate for attention we do have ways
to help you get therapy you know and
people smirk because they're like this
is wholesome but also kind of insulting
um and I have like all of these talks
with my viewers about how to handle
these people how to handle negativity
how to handle the negative in yourself
and I think a lot of the people that are
really prominent in my community because
I have a Discord server aside with
thousands and thousands of people I
think it's like got 40 000 people in and
they all support each other and they're
a great social network but they
a lot of them used to be really toxic a
lot of them used to be [ __ ] and um I
get a lot of DMS from people who were
like I was a terrible person until I
found your stream and I found all these
people and I've learned some social
skills and I'm here in this community my
community meet up with each other
they're marrying each other you know I'm
hoping there'll be some little
based babies happening soon you know
it's really cute so I'm glad these toxic
people find me because when they go and
rant and Rave in other streams they're
not going to get the infrastructure to
actually have some real attention and
that was what it was about like people
don't
come and be inflammatory for no reason
it's because they don't know how to
believe that the good side of them will
ever be appreciated they don't think
that if they're just themselves anyone
will like them and you know socialize
with them so they act up to get a
reaction because it's less lonely when
someone's reacting to you it doesn't
matter why
um so when trolls come into my stream
I've got a viewer base that can identify
what's happening and make friends with
them calm them down a little bit and uh
yeah like a few months later they're
coming to twitchcon and drinking with
them all and just amazing happy and
um
it's really uh impressive what you're
saying there about trying to
fix the trolls because ultimately the
easy thing to do is to tell them to [ __ ]
off or whatever and then like well I do
that too thoroughly no but nothing ever
changes but like it's interesting now
because we've heard the the good side of
it for you the the positive impact it's
had on your life as well as some of the
negatives
what's next for you like what's the next
five years are you kind of living each
day each week each year as it comes or
do you have plans okay so part I
mentioned earlier my brain doesn't
I struggle with certain Concepts I have
no concept of time okay we see see you
in an hour I don't that's like a map to
a place and I don't know where that
place is I just can't find it on the map
like
an hour could be 20 minutes it could be
three days to me I just can't gauge it
very well and this means that I'm not
planning anything and since I stopped
planning my life's gotten so much better
because when I try to plan with that
level of disability none of those plans
go well I guess I I got I got sort of
two more questions before we've done
like the first one is um
do you feel like Tourette's defines you
or do you feel like it's part of you you
know when you meet someone with for the
first time do you feel that you should
say by the way I have Tourette's or is
that something that slipped into the
background in more recent life because
when I first
started seeing your videos it was very
much like The Tourettes were always in
the title of the videos I'd seen where
there was other people posting them or
whatever
whereas now that doesn't seem to be as
big a thing it seems to be more just a
gaming thing
okay
um
firstly I'll say no I'm not my
Tourette's at all my Tourette's has
nothing to do with my identity it's just
a condition I manage that's like saying
someone is their eczema like I don't
choose what I handle in life
I am what I choose about myself so
I didn't choose to have Tourette's
that's not me how I handle my Tourette's
as an aspect of my identity but like
what I'm facing is just not me like you
wouldn't say someone was their trauma
you wouldn't say someone with the hair
color the things we choose about
ourselves are the things we are and so
and when I first started making content
I found it so important to put with
Tourette's in every title of everything
all the streams all the YouTube videos
because not because I was like look at
me guys I had threats it was more if I
don't explain why I'm swearing I will
get demonetized if I don't explain this
as a condition
people will rant and Rave at me in the
comments if I'm engaging with someone on
my stream and it looks like I'm sexually
harassing them or swearing at them
people will get mad at me and hate me
they have to understand this is
involuntary and if it's right there in
the title if you don't want to hear
swearing it's on you if you clicked on
it anyway whereas like people would come
in and they'd be like what if children
see this you'll get like I was getting
accused when I first arrived they're
like you don't belong here this is live
streaming like if you can't not swear
and not breach the terms of service of
twitch and not break the rules you
shouldn't be here because the rules say
you can't say the n-word you can't say
like racial slurs and things like this
which is fair and totally fine but I
can't help it so just exclude people
with disabilities if you enforce it when
people don't mean it and they're just
you know so I in that situation making
people aware that I had Tourette
Syndrome was essential to my presence it
wasn't like a way to grab an audience it
wasn't a aspect of my identity it was
just a coping strategy for a hostile
environment
but as I've become more well known
people already know that I have my
condition I mean when I hung out with
the sidemen on YouTube that video I was
on was I had 38 million views so just by
that one video alone there'll be like
millions of people who now know that I
am the Tourette's girl which means that
if I just put my own name in the content
or my own face in the thumbnail most
people know what to expect now so I can
chill a bit because people already know
what to expect and that's what the
transformation was
um because for me I feel like a lot of
people who regularly come to my streams
ask me questions that have nothing to do
with my condition you can tell a
newcomer because they're asking the same
questions over and over again about my
condition but a lot of people stay for
the other discussions luckily because
you know that's what I'm passionate
about and I'm much calmer and I tick
less when I talk book so I just want to
engage as myself not just constantly be
exhausted and have people fixate on my
condition because ticking is exhausting
um so yeah that's the overview of why
that changed and how I feel about my
condition
I think that you you've got an amazing
skill of
really being able to explain situations
in a way that make it very accessible
and easy to understand for people who
haven't been in those situations for so
even in this chat there's you know
obviously there's a Tourette's singer
being a female streamer how twitch works
like the interactions with different
people it's really fascinating to you to
listen to you and I we could go on and
on except I've got my director message
me on the iPad saying wrap it up so
um I just wanted to say you know best of
luck with the future and thanks so much
for coming back and um back off your
video I said this before but your video
was when we put it up on our Channel it
was the fastest we've ever hit a million
views so amazing fingers crossed for
this one thanks Anita
foreign
[Music]
so that was sweet and eater the twitch
streamer I'm joined Now by Josh the
director of the episode
um pretty fun
brilliant we were all cracking up in the
back she's such a great car isn't she
such a great talker yeah so just yeah
really succinct yeah
um and obviously that's layered with
some horrific stories that she's gone
through so much and
she's come through it what did you think
Brady I want her to be my friend yeah I
want to hang out with her and go for a
drink with her
um and with such wit she told
what has actually been a really
difficult life story traumatic yeah
but with such Poise and she also you
know as a female listening to that she
touched on a lot of topics that as a
female you can relate to you don't want
to relate to but is part and parcel when
she's
experienced that you know the really
hard end of that being a twitch streamer
and being at the Forefront of you know
thousands and thousands of men watching
her online dude Moda hard mode that's
what she said wasn't it yeah I felt that
online game was quite a good sort of
summary of it because that really
important thing at the start where she
could press a button and not be heard or
press a button to talk and so for the
first time she said I wasn't defined by
my Tourette's when she was meeting
people and then the dark side of it in
terms of the of the people who would
compound a guard and follow her abuse it
like it's just awful and then again
she's like made a career out of it which
she loves and she's in control of so
um but yeah there's there's a lot more
to talk about with her and and it's
interesting because you start the bit
that you start talking about is
naturally Tourette's but by the end that
just seems yeah yeah and the whistling
is really nice oh yeah the whistling I
was Mesmerizing the way today it was you
lost your trailer
a little bit of adjustment levels yeah
she's got something in her that I want
some some level of resilience and just
she you know when she said she's got
four therapists and they all said why
are you not more [ __ ] up and then she
went on to say because I've experienced
you know I've slept on the street and I
know I can do it so I could do it again
you know when humans don't think they
can dig any deeper they can and she
really epitomizes that I think it's
interesting to hear what she said as
well because we talked to a few
different YouTubers and stuff like that
and they're all talking about the next
thing as in that you know the the moving
into a new area as well as YouTube and a
lot of them are very uh clever
entrepreneurs whereas her thing is so
different it's just like the next five
minutes is where my focus is
um and it'll be interesting to see what
she does next I guess I've had always
ask this question you know you wear a
spy inside your card in the months and
the years before before 9 11. how could
how could you not have seen it coming
and I would say well we've seen it
coming that's something big is going to
happen but the details were so well
guarded because the al-Qaeda was split
into compartments the people who were
trained for that in a mission were
trained in a secret camp that was set up
for them and then they themselves in at
least 14 of them 14 out of the 19 did
not know that it was a suicide mission
they thought it was only a hijacking wow
and that's it only five